hey guys i'm philip molina and this is
my friend Kyle hi I'm Kyle I'm the new
kid at school yeah you listed his help
he's gonna go over some of the
characters I am too and we've learned so
much very recently about who these
people are
sagar era and Gaylen or so and all these
details oh and also I mean it's not only
who they are but who they might actually
be it's like Hong reddit everyone's like
uh he's Snoke except Jung it's kind of
that thing I kind of wrote every
characters Snoke
yeah or it's Ray's father or something
yeah it's a pretty in-depth coverage but
I think you're gonna like it
so let's get into it so let's start off
with Saul Guerrero this is the Forest
Whitaker character that we had a lot of
theories about before if you want to
check out our old video but now we know
a lot more about him he's basically been
the narrator too for these trailers if
you continue to fight what will you
become
and saga era isn't brand new drug one he
actually is a George Lucas original they
wanted him on the live-action TV show
that never happened but instead they
didn't use him until the Clone Wars that
3d animated show that's pretty good
actually and you might have heard his
name really quick and rebel ran into one
of your rebel friends who work for
sauger era but let's get into his actual
story a lot of people have been like oh
he was on the cartoon show but they
don't tell you anything about who he was
there so he was part of what's known on
the show is the on during art if you
don't know that's his for episode arc
and the fifth season of Clone Wars it
takes place on saws home planet of
Onderon where he and his sister steela
gerrera lead a rebellion against a
separatist and then later if they
rejoined the republic after getting help
from anakin skywalker what's super cool
though is that this is like one of the
first parts of the actual rebellion that
we're very familiar with now but someone
had to start it and these were some of
the very first people doing it so when
we see saw again in rogue one he's like
this like grizzled veteran like he has
like the beard in the hair and
everything like he looks like he's seen
some [ __ ] apparently he kind of like
pushes the boundaries of what like Bail
Organa and Mon Mothma are cool with it's
like it's kind of like terrorism oh it's
kind of terrorism so yeah yeah but when
the Death Star shows up all of a sudden
they're like getting them back in for
like one last job you know he's like a
loose cannon cop in like an 80s movie
where it's like I don't like you Sagara
but damn do you get results
on moth non-talking yeah yes she's like
smoking a stogie damn you yeah but on a
real note I saw is speaking from
experience when he says that line what
will you he has seen some [ __ ] actually
and if you think you're gonna go back
and watch at the cartoon show then maybe
skip to this time right here if you
don't want to know what happened to saw
on the TV show but in the aundre narc
he's kind of very like bullheaded I mean
he is a badass but he's very impatient
arrogant he's like Anakin and Attack of
the Clones where he's like I'm taking
him now Dovie come on it's like boy bad
boy he would you that's terrible
decision like jumping off cars yeah
space cars but at the end of that arc
his sister Stila she actually ends up
being killed and oh my god this is so
heartbreaking it's cuz saw shot down a
gunship and it freakin crashes in her
eyes right into her so you know I think
he feels responsible for her dad which
he should so I'm imagining that's what's
kind of led to this like crazy grizzled
veteran yeah it's worth like the part
they cut out of the trailer was his
monologue saying like don't shoot your
sister with a rocket what your engines
like what are you that walking that's
way not relevant at all yeah or how did
you know yeah oh and by the way remember
how so Darth Vader now we know spoiler
he's in rogue one SAW has history with
Anakin Skywalker
yeah they fought side by side in that
arc that we're talking so if he knows
that Darth Vader is Anakin Skywalker
which you probably does yeah they could
interact in this movie yeah which
hopefully it's like a thing where they
see each other and there's some sort of
line like if they even remotely
acknowledge it like I will just grab my
bucket of popcorn and throw it at the
screens that a happy thing when you
throw hope you found yes because it's
like I'm giving the screen my popcorn
FairPoint the person in front of you
loves it too anyway let's move on to
captain captain and or he's a rebel
intelligence officer who he happens to
look like Luke's friend uh Biggs dark he
also looks just like um kind of like
when the first trailer came out everyone
was like that's Kyle Katarn which like
if you don't say that I was like it
could be come on yeah yeah cuz like if
you don't know who that is he's like a
kind of from the extended University was
introduced in a bunch of the videogames
like we talked about him a ton in the
other video world John if you want I
guess just everyone in this universe
looks like like a sophomore in college
with their page
clothing so either way I like Demeter
wise he's almost like like the good guy
almost Captain America of the group uh
he's just practical normally by the
books except in this situation he seems
to be bending the rules for Jen it's
kind of weird like look at what he says
right here are you really doing this I
want to help
so casseon is an intelligence he
recruits people so it's kind of weird
that he just kind of jumps on board and
wants to go on this incredibly dangerous
mission with Ginny yeah it definitely
feels like it's her mission probably a
suicide mission and yet he's like hey me
too please you know the part where that
they show the robot guy for the first
time she says this the captain says you
are a friend I will not kill you
Thanks so he says don't kill her she's
my friend
and I think that's really weird if they
don't really know each other it's like
they're kind of like coworkers you know
what I mean they're in the rebellion
together exactly like out imagine
there's like more than ten people in the
office there but maybe he's like hitting
on iron he's like she's my she's my
friend leave that door open yeah
so actually that's a good segue to talk
about k2s oh this big badass robot
voiced by alan tudyk who is hilarious
and amazing and watch all of fireflies
yes as just perfect for fireflies oh
he's a imperial enforcer droid that
casseon and or actually reprogrammed to
fight with the rebels you can tell he's
got the little patch on its arm or print
on his arm tattoo on his arm yeah that
makes him Empire property but Kassian
freed him so he used to be a security
droid or something but now he's
definitely just kind of like a loyal
sidekick almost kind of like Chewbacca -
Han maybe they also have a life-debt
that he kind of read actually uh alan
tudyk said that it's kind of more like a
paternal kind of because he like gave
life to him so it's kinda almost like
more like c-3po and anakin what
relationship is closer than c-3po anakin
yeah cheffy a important point to make
though because he was a badass like
security droid before he still is like
very lethal and threatening as hell
which is why yes yeah be told hey don't
kill everybody please yes he doesn't
really have like a human element to him
almost I mean that's the dumbest
sounding thing I've ever said because
he's a robot
but he doesn't have he's very blunt
about things he's kind of like uh did
you ever play Knights The Old Republic
yeah there was that droid guy named HK
47 damn it Master I am an assassination
droid not a dictionary and he had like
this kind of like really like sardonic
like blunt way of just talking about
mortality I optical sensors simply pick
up all the water sloshing about inside
your flesh Cody
it is unpleasant yeah I just no longer
in the extended universe so this is like
the closest we could get to seeing him
on screen can't have a normal droid he
has to be like I'm HK 47 yeah he doesn't
have a son
I'm a simple southern droid yeah so I
check out actually this clip where this
wasn't in any of the trailers but he
refuses to like carry anyone's bag -
yeah he has truly been freed so I guess
that makes sense also uh this new
trailer gave us the first real look at
Bodie rook which is actually one of the
main characters that we haven't seen too
much from he's kind of the pilot of the
group he was also kind of like the Droid
guy he jumped ship from being the Empire
to help out the rebellion as well same
yeah yeah save that [ __ ] but I got
matching tattoos yeah I don't think it's
a tattoo when it's on your clothes yeah
I think he's super interesting because
in Star Wars every character is kind of
like the best star fighter in the world
like I'm the best pilot in the galaxy
but he's just like hi I'm a I'm kind of
like the truck driver the galaxy like he
literally described his character that
way yeah Riz Ahmed did which by the way
Riz Ahmed if you're watching the night
of he's amazing he's so different the
same guy same freakin guy oh my god how
amazing this guy is Anna Bob everything
he's British so I'm sort of researching
this video didn't make that connection
okay he's he's also in a bunch of other
stuff he's so good but something else
about him here in this movie he's not a
happy-go-lucky guy in fact he seems kind
of like a jerk at least according to the
descriptions that leaked so far which is
totally perfect for a movie where you
get kind of like The Outlaws or ever and
you put them together like former Empire
pilots and join stuff you don't want
this like we are really great a team
right yeah like you want a group that
kind of is ragtag and you know unlikely
group of misfits is what we're looking
yeah like some sort of moving on also I
don't think that they kind of went to
the planet for him
I think they weren't like let's go find
that truck driver I think you need to
recruit him to be on exactly I don't
think I think he just kind of got swept
up and I think even Riz Ahmed kind of
you know let us onto believe that one of
the interviews he said something along
the lines of a passion was ignited in
his character which I would imagine is
him deciding to go FPU Empire I'm being
a pilot for these guys maybe he helps
some escape and then just becomes part
of the team because you can't really
jump around yeah yeah I'll but up next
our next year to talk about well all
these names by the way the
pronunciations aren't official
yet I think it's baisemeaux 'bless I
think his name is Deadshot know if he is
the ho an assassin he kind of even if
you imagine with the helmet or something
kind of looks like everybody's favorite
assassin Boba Fett
so his homeworld is jet ha we had that
line in the trailer destroyed uh kind of
like like a Jedi
ha ha I don't know if it's gonna do so
well but it seems like that's why he
goes down this road of even more
violence than he probably has used
that's why you an assassin might join up
with the rebels right and I think it is
important to keep in mind like when you
look at this guy like he is the image of
violence right yes gotta his weapon is a
heavy blaster yes it's like a proton
backup yeah he's definitely like built
for violence and probably not religion
yeah no that's what Jedi is known for
it's kind of like a mecca to the Jedi so
it's very interesting who they pair him
with consistently throughout the movie
it's that chirrup guy yeah it was super
spiritual all this as the force Wilson
it's almost like a monk warrior sure it
is in a lot of ways like the opposite of
right Bates
it's an opposite yeah he's blind he's a
frickin he's all spiritual his only
weapon is a bo staff which is probably
the polar opposite of a heavy Peter
cannon yet he's the one that we see
kicking the most ass in the Train ya
know when I first saw him I thought he
was like a force guy I thought he had he
was force sensitive but it turns out
right isn't he turns out he just like
worships the force like a religion now
right it reminds me of various people
like supposedly Maz Kanata we're not
sure if she's positive or not but also
lor san tekka is like someone who's
always been a supporter of the forest
for san tekka by the way is a member of
a kind of religion that is adjacent to
the forces you don't have to be poor
Spencer to be part of it the idea being
that when the Empire took over took care
of all the Jedi
they said the Jedi were bad guys people
had to go underground if they still
wanted to keep in touch with the force
so there was this whole underground
religion called the Church of the force
and that was what lor San Tekka did I'm
hoping that they even named drop it in
this movie yeah there's a good chance
that they could connect the forces of
the original trilogy through rogue one
to the new
to Jane through this turret character
yet when I saw force awakens I wondered
well who is this Laura San Tekka guy but
he was pretty important with this kind
of thing it'd be cool to see maybe a
cameo from him oh definitely be the
rite-aid that brings us to the guy who
is the coolest name in the entire movie
Orson chronic director director Orson
Critic so we know darth vader is in this
movie but the main antagonist is this
Orson chronic guy this is the guy that
when we first saw him in all-white we
were like Hello in our video which you
guys can check out again we were like
could this be freaking throng yeah which
again drawn is really not not in this
movie it's worth watching that other
video just so you can hear this guy's
story he's such a badass Grand Admiral
Thrawn and while he's not gonna be in
this movie they did just doubt he's
coming to the cartoon yeah this fall I
think he's making his new extended
universe debut of rebels yeah
either way the fact that they have the
main villain of this dressed as one of
the most iconic Star Wars villains you
kind of attach a lot of that emotional
baggage to that it's kind of like how
kylo Ren is kind of Darth Vader II in a
way you can't really put your finger on
so you just mean oh I can put my finger
all over it yeah yeah it's the voice of
the mask it's a cloak yeah yeah we know
that
Orson chronic is trying to get in good
with Emperor Palpatine when you're kind
of up high and like the leadership with
the bad guys in the Empire it kind of
gets a little cutthroat I find your lack
of faith disturbing
enough of this Vader release him so I'm
hoping that they have a similar thing
with Darth Vader and cronic that they
kind of did with kylo Ren and general
Hux in the force awakens where they were
both trying to get Snoke to go to prom
with them you know what I mean they were
both trying to impress Snopes I'm kind
of hoping that this shows Darth Vader
who's kind of like the Emperor's pawn
for a while that's why the return of the
Jedi is such a big deal wing Chuck's one
of the things that they cut out the most
by removing the extended universe is
just how chaotic the Empire itself can
be and the tensions between the military
and the Sith and the Emperor and Darth
Vader there's always a lot of tension
there and feel like they're starting to
bring that back we saw in a force
awakens we definitely could see it here
in rogue one so director chronic he's
actually the director the supreme
military director for the Empire
specifically he's directing the advanced
weapons research the death star is his
baby it took like 20 years to make the
thing it was long delayed allegedly but
he was the guy who's like let's get this
done
in the original trilogy between the
first Death Star and the second Death
Star it's like four years yeah but at
the end of Revenge of the Sith they're
like well it's almost done and then 20
years happens and then it's done I want
to also see a movie about the delay it's
like the bureaucracy there we go that
stuff like bills and stuff there's no
there's no bills in Congress because
it's an empire yeah not just the emperor
stamping each thing yes yeah a little
checkbook Oh also real quick I do want
to add in the celebration video I think
we've seen younger director Orson Critic
we can't see him very closely so he has
I but he does have the white Club so I
will has that it does look like it's
like only half as long like a girl's
long to age he looks like he's going
after specifically I think that's Galen
or so Jin's father
so who's Galen Ursa we don't know much
about Galen Ursa who's played by Mads
Mikkelsen he's been estranged from his
daughter Jin for a he resumed ibly since
she was 15 because we know she's been on
her own since she was that old but that
estrangement could be a result of
chronic capturing him making him work on
the Death Star cuz we do know he is a
scientist right and he if I remember
correctly they he's described somewhere
as like the Oppenheimer of Star Wars yes
Oppenheimer is the guy probably most
responsible for designing the nuclear
bomb and I'm pretty sure he's famous for
not being too stoked about being part of
that everybody saw what he did he wasn't
like yeah so I would imagine that's a
really cool parallel to play with this
he's actually the person who sent the
message that Mon Mothma talks about here
we have intercepted a coded Imperial
transmission the message was sent by
your father right so a couple
possibilities here as to what exactly is
going on with him he either ended up
helping design the Death Star now feels
really guilty about it sends out a
message and they specifically go for his
daughter Jin or so cuz they're like hey
you have a vested interest in getting
this guy back or we don't know for sure
that this guy feels guilty yeah maybe
maybe he is just absorbed by the Empire
now and maybe that's what he's become is
then and they're still trying to use jyn
erso his daughter to try to break
through to him maybe he's the rogue one
listen a movie name in the movie yeah
maybe he is the Star Wars story but
let's light about his baby well baby Jin
a little baby Jin what we know about her
is well the first trailer opens up with
just listing her offenses forgery of
Imperial documents possession of stolen
property
aggravated assault resisting arrest we
also know she's been on her own since
the age of 15 mon mothma says that on
your own from the age of 15 that clearly
gives her a chip on her shoulder you
know she makes it very clear that she's
rebellious like even with a turn of
phrase
that's how rebellious she is sizzle
abelian isn't it IRA bail Kathleen
Kennedy who is president of the my heart
president of LucasArts but she said that
Jin is kind of like a Joan of Arc
character which if you know anything
about Joan of Arc she's a brilliant
military leader comes from a peasant
background but hopefully it doesn't end
the same way because Joan of Arc was
burned alive so I don't know if she's
hinting that there's a bad ending here
cuz that does really sound like I mean
I'll say that's like being like she's
kind of like an Abraham Lincoln
character that doesn't mean happily ever
after
we've talked about this in our other
video I still think every character in
this movie can die except for Darth
Vader that actually brings us to our
theories here ah activate theory time
so if she didn't die I think there's a
way she could be raised mom definitely a
way she's ready to yeah she looks like
her right I guess every woman in the
Star Wars universe kind of just looks
the same though whoa he said that his
machine just Twitter
she is Jesus they're all white and they
all have Runet hair look at them like
look at the pictures it could they're
all related probably you know I'm not
the bad guy here what about the
nonhumans there our girl he walks back
to point if she is this age and she
happens to meet some you know must I
look Skywalker maybe they can hit it all
this of course is if Luke ends up being
raised dad which who knows but this
theory I guess also still ends with her
dying because where is she now he likes
you had Rey
but then she dies yeah is she the
tombstone at the end of force awakens I
will say though if she doesn't die with
the advertisement so far with the
teasers and the trailers and Forest
Whitaker's narration they're really
hammering down the point of will she
become a bad guy what will you become so
let's say she does turn evil
who does she turn into Snoke mmm snow
peas she's Snoke she's smoked you that
looks like it the same person to you
okay I'll give you one better
she could be Captain phasma we do know
there's a different actress playing
Captain phasma
Gwendoline Christie yes we hear voice
kinda but she does have she doesn't yeah
she has a similar accent and it could be
like uh what's the name Sebastian Shaw
who played Darth Vader or turn of a Jedi
where it's like a different like messed
up version she could be like the warrior
I've been through hell version okay you
like a quarter sold me that that's a
possibility I'll take it I still love
the idea that she just raised mom I want
everyone to be related to everybody but
there's another theory out there about
who these people actually are or better
yet who they all become I don't want to
add too much credence to it but some
people think that this group of ragtag
individuals they become the Knights of
Ren
I hate it I don't I don't want that to
be true but there are some similarities
so there's like similar shoulder armor
this guy has like a staff if you look at
the actual force awakens where they show
the Knights around this guy does have a
bo staff and the only other person we've
seen with that is Rey I'm not even gonna
say that's a theory but just opening up
a can of worms and I think I guess the
craziest part is the last one on this
thing is named the rogue so how weird is
that
one says Rogan one says rogue old aim of
the movie yeah I don't want this to be
true but if it is it would be freakin
crazy
you want it to be true yeah no I just
want it to be the most mind-blowing
thing on they all they come tonight to
run yeah it'd be interesting I
definitely I let us know in the comments
by the way if you have any questions
about any of the other characters with
these characters biographies we'll try
to hit you back you can also tweet at us
if you have those questions here our
twitter handle to know his and really
quick if you want a shirt like this or
things like this it's from loot crate so
hit up loot crate loot crate comm slash
rockstars can use the code rockstars and
you get 10% off and you get stuff like
this it's cool
uh but that's it we did it we you did it
I did it you guys tell everybody thank
you guys so much for watching thank you
for supporting us on patreon you guys
are amazing and again we make these
videos because you let us share this
video if you thought it was useful and
check out our other rogue one videos if
you have a second otherwise I'll see you
later bye
that's a gross sound hello
you